so let's suppose that's a sort of
rough-and-ready picture of what hope is
how does it help in the face of
something like the Anthropocene so let's
say we hope for carbon justice right
that was the thing that we said we
wanted to degree guardrail fair
distribution of what remains say we hope
for that that means according to the
what I was just telling you that we
believe it's possible certainly seems
possible we want it we even think we're
morally required to go for it in this
case and we tenaciously focus on that
possibility we consider it we fantasize
about it we imagine what it would be
like to get there we think about how our
hopes would be dashed if we didn't get
there and what the consequences would be
but we keep it rational we don't go into
a kind of optimism that suggests that
our evidence is different than it is so
it's a hopeful pessimism if you will and
how does that avoid getting into
demoralisation in the way that I
suggested sometimes we can in the face
of long odds well I mean if you're
tenaciously focused on the positive
possibility I think it's very
psychologically natural to then start
thinking about as I said before pathways
ways in which you might be involved or
at least someone might be involved in
getting to the ultimate outcome getting
out of the prison for instance so once
you start thinking that way you kind of
build yourself and maybe your community
the people working with you into the
hope so you start hoping not just for
this outcome but for that outcome and
that I contribute to it in some way so I
hope to contribute through all of this
effort to the bringing about of this
outcome so with respect to carbon
justice all the little things I try to
do I want them to make a difference
something we hear a lot from a lot of
people certainly my students I want to
me how do I make a difference that seems
really key a kind of consequentialist
picture now I think that when we look
closely at the odds and how much we can
really do as individuals even if we say
yeah I'm hoping to make a difference for
carbon justice we could still face
demoralization we could still face these
long odds and sort of think yeah
actually it's not going to matter much
so here's the final twist I'm talking
about hope for specific outcome
and just skipped hope as a virtue for
the sake of time I can go back to that
if we want to in the question and answer
so here's the final twist as we know
there are some systems especially in
nature but also in culture and commerce
that are not linear systems this is
something that actually comes up in a
lot of the discussions here I think in
the long now context sometimes it's not
just about aggregates and linear
progressions but rather about feedback
loops and sudden shifts and thresholds
and trigger points and so forth now what
is the chance that you and your the
people you convince around you or the
people who are working around you for
carbon justice are going to be on a
tipping point or a threshold very small
right even smaller than the possibility
that I was talking the probability of
that one possibility I was talking about
before that you'll make some sort of
difference the thought here is it's
still possible it's still possible that
you'll make this huge difference that
your small actions will come at just the
right moment such that the system trips
in across the tipping point or across
the threshold and you make a big
difference I think if we focus in this
hopeful way on that mere possibility and
it is possible in many cases then it
will be very difficult to feel
demoralized then it will feel be very
difficult to think I'll just sort of let
this one slide I will opportunistically
go ahead and burn this carbon when I
really don't need to let me just finish
by illustrating this with a case and now
we're going to go back to the food
situation which is what the book was in
part about so we know that industrial
animal agriculture is one of the worst
greenhouse gas producers it's worse than
the entire transportation sector
combined we also know it's kind of more
intuitive in this context to see what I
was talking about with thresholds and
nonlinear ality so there's a kind of
chunkiness about the supply chain in a
huge opaque system like this where it's
not the case that when I stop and get a
chicken sandwich
you know which is made up of maybe one
fiftieth of a chicken depending on
other things they put in there that
somehow 150th of a chicken dies right so
it's not this direct correlation even if
I have 50 sandwiches it might not be the
case that one chicken dies there's you
know this thing going along this system
and it hits thresholds and at some point
some choice does have this big effect a
hundred thousand chickens are ordered
and the farmer produces them and they
become part of the 45 billion chickens
that are processed every year so suppose
I really care about the climate or about
animals or about both and I decided to
give up on animal products facing these
huge numbers makes it hard to be
optimistic makes it hard to think that
you're going to be making a difference
that demoralization threat comes in and
what I want to suggest is that we can
sort of generate and I already sort of
casually made it but now I'm going to
formally make it a moral argument what
calls a moral argument for lived hope
that would help us avoid demoralization
in this kind of case and in Anthropocene
cases generally so you can't get through
a talk by a philosopher without one
effort at a stepwise argument so here's
premise one oppy this is the guy who's
thinking about opportunistically you
know he's demoralized and he's like I'm
just gonna eat that chicken sandwich
because it doesn't make a difference I
do care about the factory farm system
I'm morally opposed to its continuation
but I'm tempted by the thought that if I
make a difference at the miniscule
difference a tempting thought that we
all have early it would be demoralizing
in that way that I was mentioning for
oppe to have not to have some sort of
hope that his eating choices or the
choices of those he influences have a
significant effect on the factory farm
system so suggesting unless we can focus
on the positive possibility that we make
a significant difference we might face
demoralization demoralization is morally
undesirable especially if the end in
question is something we think is
morally required or duties to future
generations and so forth so given the
facts about the system that is chunky
and not linear in the way I was
suggesting earlier suggests that there's
a more
advantage in having rational hope that
at least one of the food choices you
make throughout your life if you have 20
or 30 thousand choices left at least one
of those choices is going to be a
threshold choice where you actually get
to decide whether the system shunts
forward whether there was a hundred
thousand chickens get ordered or not the
threshold chicken is yours at that
moment you don't know which and so you
sort of then try to abstain across all
of your choices and have this hope that
one of them makes a huge difference a
hundred thousand chickens or not
depending on how you choose so other
things equal rational hope that at least
one of the food choices he makes or
influences is a threshold choice becomes
morally justified so for moral reasons
we can hope for that it's not it's not
optimism it's not the claim that that is
going to happen that would be crazy
right think about the odds but I'm
suggesting it's both morally justified
so there's a compelling moral reason to
focus on that mere possibility in the
way that hope does in order to keep us
from being demoralized
[Music]